my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here my tiny corner of nowhere
there's nowhere left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
[Music]
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do
[Music]
but they stay because of all the things
they can be can you feel this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead
I created a hidden-object an easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning find him this is just a game
I'm talking about two life-and-death
stuff the Oasis
the world's most important economic
resource this is nothing less than a war
for control of the future
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
like many of you I only came here to
escape
[Music]
but I found something much bigger than
just myself
are you willing to fight help us save
the Oasis
[Music]